[panting]
I am trapped down here all the exits are
closed and it's after me I don't know if
anyone will ever see this but you
need to know that you need to know
hello internet welcome to film theory the
show that reminds you to never trespass on
private property because you might just get
stuck in an analog horror series ladies and
gentlemen Kane pixels has done it again taking
a break from working on his back rooms feature
film to give us a brand new series known as
The Oldest View and while the series certainly
draws a lot of ideas and inspiration from
Kane's back rooms videos something that the
series itself calls out
it is still very much its own thing
in case you've missed this one
The Oldest View is a more cinematic piece than
Kane's previous backrooms videos combining
his trademark found footage style with a couple
of scenes that are more traditionally shot
in the series we find ourselves behind the
camera of a college YouTube vlogger named
Wyatt in what starts off as a normal hiking
vlog Wyatt takes us to this weird hole that
he found at the base of a large tree revealing
a staircase that descends straight down into
the earth and out of sight and as any good
youtuber would Wyatt decides to enter this
obviously dangerous mysterious stairwell all
in pursuit of that sweet sweet content at
the bottom almost a mile underground he finds
something completely unexpected an abandoned
shopping mall but unfortunately for Wyatt
though the mall's devoid of human life he
isn't alone slowly he's stalked by a mysterious
monster a large papier-mâché statue on wheels
pulled straight out of the uncanny valley a
statue who seems to hate the fact that his
home has been disturbed let me tell you I
wasn't sure that Kane was going to be able
to recapture the mysterious and horrific lightning
in a bottle that he found with the backrooms
but it's been a while since a piece of media
like this has kept me at the edge of my seat
and of course just like with the backrooms
Kane has packed this thing to the gills with
tons of hidden lore and blink and you'll miss
it references in other words it was practically
begging for an episode the questions here
are just too intriguing not to dive into what
is The Oldest View really about what's with
this rolling giant thing and why is it stalking
an abandoned mall heck what even is the deal
with that mall and why is it a mile underground
what when you actually stop and do the research
underneath the layers of analog horror is
a touching story about longing for the past
and how to embrace nostalgia without getting
consumed by it the craziest part all of it
is told through the lens of real people real
places and real history yeah the monster here
it really exists so grab your camera phones
and let's go to the mall loyal theorists
it's time we head down the stairs into the
oldest view so I feel like the best place
to start is with a quick recap of the events
that we see in the series itself the first
episode is a bit of a strange one given Kane's
previous releases it's a lot more atmospheric
and traditionally cinematic than his previous
work with the backrooms we open in a forest
here we see a man walking around picking flowers
and scribbling in a small notebook but what's
interesting is that while the forest around
him is bustling with life full of the green
color that you'd expect to find in the woods
the man himself is black and white literally
monochromatic that said we don't stick around
with this guy long quickly cutting the scenes
of someone's terrifying arts and crafts project
eventually creating an ominous mask wonder
if that one's gonna come up again spoiler
alert it does the second and third episodes
take on a style a lot closer to what we've
been used to putting us in the shoes of Wyatt
the YouTube vlogger that we mentioned at the
top of the episode what's up guys Wyatt here
Wyatt takes his viewers down the mysterious
stairwell that he found in the middle of nowhere
descending down and out of sight before eventually
finding himself in that abandoned mall after
exploring around for a bit Wyatt finds that
all the stores are closed and that the exits
of the mall just lead out to rock walls but
while it seems Wyatt is alone at first he
eventually runs into this nightmare fuel this
isn't just some weird modern art piece this
creature known as the rolling giant starts
to follow Wyatt around the mall an inanimate
object somehow coming to life and stalking
him deciding that the views just aren't gonna
be worth it Wyatt heads back to the stairs
where he entered only to find that he's been
caved in he's trapped in here with this murderous
paper mache monster and only a few options
while running from the creature Wyatt finds
himself in the mall's back
room hallways eventually
leading to an office space that has a map
of the mall and directions to another exit
but as Wyatt leaves the office back rooms
and heads back into the main part of the mall
it's changed it's become overgrown by plants
and wildlife undeterred Wyatt begins climbing for
the exit that he found on the map unfortunately
the rafters collapse and Wyatt falls only
for the episode to once again shift into a
more cinematic atmospheric scene similar
to those of the first episode here we see
Wyatt's corpse and broken phone laying in the
dirt of the same forest from the beginning
as the giant looks on hidden in the trees
so huh what the heck's going on with this
thing well the way I see it there are three
main mysteries in the series so far number
one what's up with the mall number two what
is this monster supposed to be and number
three what's it all trying to tell us so let's
just do our best to break down what we can
starting with what's going on in the mall
almost immediately after discovering it Wyatt
finds a sign designating this as Valley View
Center there are also a bunch of references
to the city of Dallas Texas I keep seeing
Dallas show up I thought this was a really
strange and specific detail so we did a bit of
digging we found that the Valley View Center
is actually a very real place that actually
existed in Dallas Texas but we should also
note that the series clearly doesn't take
place in Dallas and likely not in Texas at
all first off the flora and landscape in the
outdoor area that we see towards the beginning
of why it's of logs looks a lot more like what
you'd expect to find in Central California
this absolutely makes sense when you consider
that Kane is from that part of California
but it's not just a production decision as
why it's exploring them all he himself seems
to think it's weird that he keeps seeing signs
for Dallas everywhere I keep seeing Dallas
show up I'm not sure if it's talking about
the city but I've seen like two Texas shops
and it's on a lot of signs so right off the
bat that's pretty darn weird right what's
this mall from Dallas Texas doing in California
and maybe more importantly why is it underground
well it's important to note that the Valley
View Center doesn't actually exist anymore
just like most other malls in the US the Valley
View Center was hit hard by the 2000s thanks
in large part to online shopping and companies
like Amazon taking much of their business
by 2012 the mall was bought out by an investment
group called Beck Ventures who didn't plan
to save the dying mall but instead demolish
it and rebuild the land into a completely
different shopping district known as Dallas
Midtown in fact you can see part of Beck's
plan to do this inside of The Oldest View
as why it's exploring the office space you
can spot several artistic renderings and publicity
images displayed on one of the walls that
he walks by the very same ones that you can
find in real life if you go to the actual
website for the Dallas Midtown project see
side by side there they are one and the same
why is that a big deal well it's at this point
that we should stop and acknowledge that because
this building was entirely demolished earlier
this year it means that everything we see
inside The Oldest View here is 100% CGI everything
from the giant AMC to the name eight vegetables
that start with B sign all painstakingly recreated
digitally and if the comments from Dallas
locals are any indication he did a bang up
job of bringing their memories to life I don't
just bring that up to show how impressive
Kane's work here is he chose this specific
mall and these specific assets on the walls for
reasons and it all comes down to the rolling
giant that stalks Wyatt throughout the video
why well this leads us to mystery number two
what's the deal with the monster follow me
here like most cities do Dallas is no stranger
to gas and up their local celebrities that
either came from the city or help put the
city on the map but while most other cities
would just leave it at building statues or
naming buildings after that famous person
Dallas does something a little bit different
with their metaphorical Giants they turn them
into literal Giants see in 2012 a group of
local artists in Dallas organized something
they call the Parade of Giants where many
famous Dallasonions from the city's past
would be lovingly recreated as large statues
statues that would then get rolled through
the streets you see where I'm going with this
one right at the same time as the Parade of
Giants before the Valley View Center was sold
and demolished many of its storefronts were
rented to local artists to showcase their
work in a push known as the gallery at Midtown
this has become a haven for local Dallas artists
while this mall is undergoing a transition
something we see referenced not only on the
first sign that Wyatt comes across but also
all across the mall one of these artists was
Kevin Obregon we can actually see his studio
among others as Wyatt strolls across the mall
and the giant that he created for the parade
yep it is one in the same with the giant that
we see stalking Wyatt throughout the mall
a statue who was the literal poster child
for the Parade of Giants so if these statues
are meant to be real people important to Dallas
history who is this giant based on well according
to the description for the third episode the
creature is credited to Obregon and named
the Julien Reverchon Giant if you didn't know
and I mean why would you know this Julien
Reverchon was a botanist someone who studies
plants born in France in 1837 now those factoids
right there should already be connecting some
dots for you firstly the giant itself seems
to be made of plants notice those massive
plant like hands secondly the stairwell down
to this creepy abandoned mall it was found
at the base of a large tree again showing a
connection with plants and finally our point
of view character Wyatt what's he studying
in college again oh yeah botany I was able
to get a couple of trail cameras from my old
botany professor clearly there's meant to
be a connection here and perhaps this is a
clue as to why the mall is so far underground
beneath a tree it is the roots to our story
anyway in 1856 Julien Reverchon and his father
moved to the US heading for a settlement called
La Reunion which is now Dallas Texas unfortunately
travel took ages back in the 1800s by the
time they eventually got there La Reunion
had basically collapsed instead of just turning
around though and heading back to France Reverchon
stuck around and joined the nearby community
of Dallas back when it was only a few hundred
farmers and from there he was pretty instrumental
in the development of Dallas into the metropolis
that it is today becoming something of a local
celebrity while expanding his plant collections
and teaching others about botany at Baylor
University College Reverchon Park in the city
was even named after Julien after he died
Reverchon is clearly an important person to
the story not only is this creature based
on a real sculpture of the guy but it isn't
the only time that he shows up during the
third episode when Wyatt returns to the store
that he found the giant in there's a portrait
of a man in one of the storefronts labeled
Julien Reverchon in front of it is a single
twig with leaves on it a nod to the giant
and Reverchon's career as a botanist finally
Reverchon is also our connection to the mysterious
man in the first episode of The Oldest View
remember that guy the dude stuck in black
and white while the rest of the forest is
green well on IMDB the character is credited
as Julien Reverchon he's the dude who's out here
existing in nature picking flowers scribbling
in his notebook doing his general botanisty
things which brings us then to mystery number
three why what does any of this even mean
this series clearly has a lot of very specific
very regional references to real world people
events in history this stuff was not put here
on accident this isn't meant to be a bunch
of easter eggs or random decisions this all
means something and I think we can decipher
it starting here in the back rooms of the
mall well in the office Wyatt finds himself
a piece of paper that describes fire safety
protocols for the Valley View Center it is
very detailed it even refers to several other
documents with numbers on them each with a
specific purpose but if you break down the
numbers they all have hidden meanings they're
all dates that describe very specific periods
of time document 1855 1857 can be broken down
into the years 1855 and 1857 the exact date
range that the La Reunion settlement outside
of Dallas existed remember this was the place
that Reverchon was leaving France for before
the community collapsed and Reverchon was forced
to move to Dallas the next document one nine
seven three two oh two three refers to the
dates 1973 to 2023 if you dig into the history
of the Valley View Center mall you'll find
that it was first built in 1973 and that the
last remnant of it was demolished earlier
this year in 2023 and finally the third document
references 1837 and 1905 the years Reverchon
was born and died but we can actually take
things even deeper by looking at the instructions
attached to each of these numbers see these
aren't just easter eggs they're clues to tell
us what the series is trying to say at least
thematically document 1855
1857 the one referencing
La Reunion refers to emergency assembly points
places to safely gather in the event of a
fire described as a safe distance from the
building if it were ever to have structural
issues from damage if this is meant to be
where you go in the case of an emergency it
cannot be a coincidence that the numbers are
pointing to a town that ultimately didn't
survive it's pretty ironic one that's even
more interesting though is document 1837 1905
the one pointing to Revachon's life this one
is talking about what people should do if the
exit routes become inaccessible in other words
this document seems to be thematically telling
us the way out of this situation the way to
solve Wyatt's problem and escape from this
danger is going to be looking at Reverchon
himself his life his decisions what was important
to him and what the giant represents throughout
the series what do I mean by that well think
about what we actually see the Reverchon giant
doing throughout the videos he aggressively
follows Wyatt and spooks him but he doesn't
kill Wyatt in fact the only real indication
that we have of what the giant's after as
the giant corners him Wyatt asks what do you
want and the giant shows him something strange
the lights flicker and suddenly there's a
pair of dead horses and dead men on the floor
these are clearly things that Reverchon the
real one would have witnessed at some point
during his life these men dressed in old timey
clothes and the horses and whatnot classic
cowboy stuff all a flash from Reverchon's past
and this sense of a flashback isn't just
present here in the first episode of the series
as Reverchon is picking flowers and the giant's
being made we can hear a song titled when
the swallows homeward fly and if you listen
to the lyrics they very much lean into these
same feelings of sadness and nostalgia quote
when the summer days are gone when the roses
fade and die and no more has heard the song
parting oh parting is grief and pain this
is a song about nostalgia because this is
a series about nostalgia both the good and
the bad ways that you can hold on to it honestly
this song this is what made everything click
for me as I was really sitting down to crack
the series the decision to tell this story
with Reverchon and these themes in a mall
of all places really bothered me like sure I
guess the sculpture's from here but why dive
into this particular story with this man in
this place and then it hit me just before
Wyatt exits the back rooms and finds them
all overtaken by plants you can see this poster
for just the briefest of moments it reads
do you accept this impermanence that right
there not exactly a motivational phrase you'd
expect to find in a typical workplace especially
one that has been so painstakingly recreated
by Kane no this poster was put here to make a
point and uh you know what's truly impermanent
in this series the mall it's gone it is a
vacant lot in Dallas Texas now evidence of
its impermanence for all to see that is what
The Oldest View is about it's a nostalgia
trip for anyone from the area and you don't
have to take my word for it out of the nearly
17,000 comments left on the third episode
at the time that I'm writing this Kane chose
to like just four of them each one mentioning
the strange sense of nostalgia that they got
from seeing this mall that they remember but
will never see again in real life even if
you aren't from Dallas if you're a certain age
range you're probably still gonna be feeling
a similar sense of nostalgia sure almost everyone
who's watched or will ever watch the oldest
view will have never stepped foot into the
Valley View Center but malls were very much
a ubiquitous part of American culture for
decades but as more and more of life has shifted
online it is harder and harder for malls to
stay in business many have closed their doors
forever with estimates saying that only 700
are still open in the US in 2022 nostalgia
is a powerful emotion it's bittersweet it also
brings a certain type of comfort scientists
have used nostalgia to alleviate depression
and homesickness in soldiers and I think that
is the feeling that The Oldest View is trying
to capture here despite the spoopy scary imagery
look back at those comments that people from
Dallas left about seeing Valley View in the
video none of them were sad they were grateful
they were happy to reminisce about this thing
that was a part of their lives and is now
forever gone they were able to bask in that
impermanence one final time it was important
to them to honor that memory and not to just
milk it for clout and then run away from it
afraid like Wyatt which is why he eventually
had to die impermanence is the way of nature
it's the way of life all things eventually
come to an end and you either embrace that or
else you're fighting a losing battle that's
something a botanist like Reverchon would
know all too well but hey that's just a theory
a film theory and cut